[Music]
the exciting thing about frittata is the
fact there's no set recipe because it's
basically eggs whatever else you have
left
for me the secret of a good frittata is
in the sausage nice hot pan onions in
getting this on the onions Heat
nice and high
season
fennel seeds forgive the onions
a really nice flavor everyone's used to
cooking sausages whole
but it's a really nice way of using them
to take them out of their thin skin
what we're going to do is crumple all
that wonderful spicy fennel sausage into
the onions it's going to release all
that flavor a lot quicker
pretty important to keep that gas nice
and high and the longer you caramelize
the sausage the more flavor
you're gonna gain
six whole eggs give your eggs a really
good mix
flat leaf parsley a staple in Italian
cooking chop it
quite rough
some Parmesan
it gives a really nice seasoning fresh
pepper
a little touch of salt
and then get it in there
run your fork through it so when you
slice it
no one's complaining they've got less
sausage
I'm gonna make it even more Italian by
topping it with some Buffalo mozzarella
dry it and then slice it nice and thinly
twist it
mozzarella in
and then finally finish it with that
pounds and cheese get the top just as
tasty as it is the bottom
frittata needs three and a half to four
minutes under a red Hot Grill to achieve
the best results always ensure your oven
or grill are preheated to the perfect
temperature this is the thing I love
about Italian cooking it's about sharing
but always focusing on the ingredients
look at that
I mean it's incredible a little shake
the pan to make sure it comes out and
then spatula underneath and just leave
it
it's light
fluffy and it smells incredible and that
for me is a dream come true it's amazing
how far you can take six eggs and two
sausages
wow
spicy fennel sausage frittata My
ultimate Italian breakfast it's a
cracking start to the day
it's about haddock one of my favorite
fish delicious
highly sustainable it's packed with
protein lightly smoked there's not a Dye
smoke there's a big difference so you
haven't got that bright yellow tinge so
much better
next baby spinach
the spinach that's very young full of
zinc great flavor a little teaspoon
volleyball knob of butter
that little touch of oil stops the
butter from burning
it looks like a lot of spinach
but it's going to disintegrate almost by
two-thirds I'm cooking spinach and
butter open up the top of my pepper
Mills so the pepper becomes almost like
so Cracked Pepper not so fine
once your spinach has reduced down by
two-thirds add in your cubes of smoked
haddock
tag them it's got that nice vinegary
flavor quite tart pick off the little
buds from the stalks keep hold of these
and grateful when you're making a tag of
vinegar red wine vinegar tag and stalks
in
chop the tarragon into your creme
fraiche little season
now grain mustard goes brilliantly well
with haddock
incredible this mustardy Herby creme
fresh will work equally well partnered
with grilled chicken
the haddock's starting to flake because
it's smoked lightly cured it Cooks so
quickly you creme fresh
now it's almost like the beginning of
the perfect fish pie but as opposed to
putting pastry on top the eggs are going
to bake on top so you've got this
wonderful egg crust
turn the gas off
now
crack your eggs around the outside
it's a little twist of pepper get the
remainder of your creme fresh and put a
little dollop
in between that adds richness to the egg
whites into the oven at 180
for 10 to 12 minutes
[Music]
whilst the haddock and eggs baked
together I can knock up a simple spring
onion garnish
professional kitchen chefs refuse to use
the top of the spring onions but I love
that nice dark green flavor it's less
harsh than the white the smell of baked
mustard you can't beat
[Music]
that is beautiful
spinach was almost melted in with a had
it now just sprinkle your spring onions
that gives that really nice sharpness
wow
My ultimate hearty breakfast smoked
haddock and spinach baked eggs so packed
with protein and iron you'll be raring
to dive into the day ahead
[Music]
absolutely love it why
I grew up with it there's something very
Scottish about porridge it's that kind
of sort of great start to the day my
father used to say porridge needs salt
and salt only it separates the men from
the boys didn't really like it it was
insisted salt puts hairs on you I used
to sneak a couple of sugar lumps from
cafes and put them in my porridge
without him watching these days my
porridge has much more flavor than just
salt it's packed with fruit nuts and
spices add vanilla seeds to porridge
oats or oatmeal really important just to
rub the vanilla through
the oatmeal makes it nice and fragrant
now a little teaspoon
of cinnamon makes it spicier and then
nutmeg
[Music]
already
that smells incredible I quite like
making this up week at a time and Jack
absolutely loves it now whole almonds
now if you don't like that kind of
crunch running through the porridge you
can chop these up or blend them to a
powder but I quite like the sort of
texture hazelnuts incredibly good
a really nice crunch keep your vanilla
pot in there as well that just gives it
even more lift and of course once it's
baked just pull it out instead of sugar
I'm adding sweetness with fruit fresh
pears and raisins
cranberries are great as well chopped
apricots as well dried apricots in there
dried mango I love dried fruit next pour
in a pint of milk and mix
this can be done the night before left
in the fridge and then a couple of
minutes before you go to bake it add
your cream
into your dish
it looks quite liquid but by the time it
bakes has this really nice rich crust on
top and then
just a nice little nutmeg
on top now bake at 180 for 30 to 35
minutes
then take the porridge out sprinkle on
Demerara sugar and Grill to create a
sweet Golden Crust
a sort of glaze on top
beautiful literally for three to four
minutes
look at that
that makes me feel proud to be Scottish
because it's perfect for a big Comfort
family breakfast it's Rich it's
Sumptuous and it's just a humble oatmeal
phenomenal especially in the winter my
spiced baked porridge with all those
nuts and fruit it's a bowl full of love
to start the day
[Music]
foreign